this moment
so much bigger
than me
this moment is for Dorothy Dandridge
Lena Horne Diane Carroll
it's for
the women that stand beside me Jada
Pinkett Angela Bassett Vivica Fox and
it's for every game this place this
woman of color I want to thank my mom
who's giving me the strength to fight
every single day to be who I want to be
lastly not leastly I have to thank Spike
Lee for putting me in my very first film
and believing in me Oprah Winfrey for
being the best role model any girl can
have Joe silver thank you and thank you
to Warren Beatty thank you so much for
being my mentors and believing in me
thank you thank you thank you